because for me like cold baths it's it's
like going from one extreme to the other
yeah that's why it's awesome but like I
I prefer it to be less extreme because
one one thing I do like is called Chows
cold showers is amazing not not in the
winter but if it's like a [ __ ] hot
summer's day this is like every
Southeast Asian right how cold though
huh how cold it was cold because colds
can be like 30 or cold could be like 10.
oh like I could I couldn't do it for me
for me it's like there's a there's a
perfect point for me like even in the
summer in Japan where I'm like okay I
don't want to take a hot shower because
that's yeah I'm so sorry like 20 is like
so it's not like ice cold but it's kind
of like
lukewarm let's let's say you you open
the tap water right and it's just a top
10. so yeah about 10. that's that's like
that's to me is like a cold shower right
no ice cold but you know just still cold
it's like un unheated I guess unheated
water but not chilled if that makes
sense lukewarm so what about what about
the cold bath you don't like those cold
baths are around 10 to 15 as well
normally
um sometimes it's colder depending on
where you are yeah what do you not like
about that but like about the culture
um cold shower I like the fact that
you're not dunking yourself in it it's
kind of like you can you can kind of
like Get acclimated to it a little bit
right yeah that's how you put the pinky
and then the foot and then the leg and
then the pee pee and then the body yeah
because like to me cold like
a cold bath is just like too much all at
once right it's just not it's just not a
pleasant experience yeah I don't know do
you find it a pleasant experience I like
it a lot now yeah I really like it now
at first it was kind of tough yeah but
now that I love doing it I I [ __ ]
it's the thing I gunned for whenever I
see it I think I think the video will be
out by the time this episode's out but I
recently went to go do like the
cryotherapy thing oh yeah you know when
you like put yourself in that like
machine with the liquid nitrogen they
blast you with the liquidation oh yeah
three minutes yeah it was horrible but
it was like but it was like a reverse
sauna if you think about it it's like
instead of you're getting blessed by
like you know 80 90 degrees it's like
110 130 and it's like
yeah I felt it was [ __ ] while you were
in it but the moment you walk out and
you're like you sit in front of what
they call a red light it's not it's not
a heater it's just you trick the brain
into looking at a red light and thinking
that it's warm but there's no heat right
your body's gonna heat up naturally yeah
and like that natural progression of
like heating myself up again I was like
okay now I can see why this feels good
would I do it again no I'll tell you
what the perfect balance was for me in
terms of like the nice feeling going
from hot to cold remember that ski
resort we went to earlier this year and
it was like deep in Winter we went to
the outside Onsen [ __ ] freezing
outside it was really windy so what you
do is you dunk your body into the Onsen
get a bit toasty and then you just stand
up and you just I've never fell off all
three in my life you're standing [ __ ]
naked with the [ __ ] ice cold wind
blowing on myself so to explain how cool
it was if you were sitting in there and
you didn't like wet your hair constantly
it would freeze like your hair would
actually turn solid it was averaging
about minus ten cells yeah so so we were
so we were in the
even though we were sitting in this
Onsen which was you know bath
temperature our hair would be frozen you
know our hair would be clearly my
favorite thing about it which is kind of
weird is like you know how you said you
felt like powerful like standing on yeah
I felt more powerful because like you
stand upright and and your body is just
like it the the hot air is just turning
into like Vapor yeah there as well so
it's like oh it's like gear too yeah
it was like is this how loony feels it's
like get a second bro I don't know what
that is
happening I love it but now I'm cold
holy [ __ ] that body is upset
I think having a cold shower or a cold
bath is very good for blood pressure I
think correct I believe so yeah um a lot
of people in like uh Nordic countries or
like uh Iceland they because they tend
to have cold showers or do the cold uh
don't run in the river or some [ __ ] the
dunk run foreign
[Music]
it's interesting I don't know I
definitely feel so much more relaxed and
like I don't know the next day I feel
amazing after I do it every time during
the cycling thing that I did with Chris
I was like one or two of the days there
was a sauna and it was like it was like
a relief it was like God tier I felt so
ready the next day no I totally get it
like and and I know that like you know
again there is like you know properly
scientifically backed you know health
benefits to doing sortas and Ice baths
and stuff like that yeah but like I know
that but it's like I still don't really
want to do it I I understand
it feels good I don't care about the
health benefits this is like this is
like me eating salad because I think it
tastes good and then I'm like oh
actually it is really good for you okay
I understand I know that I just I'm just
saying I just don't find it a pleasant
experience so I don't I don't normally
want to do it I'm driving you next time
I would do it I'll do it I would do it
I'd be more inclined to do it if there
were other people yeah because I've been
inside I've been in very fun with your
friends yeah
experience like I've ever had right sure
which is a bunch of mates convinced me
to go to the sauna because like yeah
we're gonna chill in there hang out and
I'm like oh [ __ ] here we go again here
we go here we go again okay I try to
meet Dragon to this thing and so you
know you go you go in the sauna I sit
down instantly my ass is way too [ __ ]
hot it feels like it's [ __ ] searing
and everyone's having a nice
conversation and I'm like fighting for
my life right now I'm like everyone's
like yeah this feels so good right now
like reacts first then because like for
me it's like my lungs feel like they're
on fire oh my lungs as well yeah so you
breathe through your uh mouth your mouth
yeah but it's still you breathe through
your mouth and you're just slow going
into like every breath of mine hurts you
sit down but your ass is searing and
it's just like
I'm so [ __ ] oh I can barely that's
why you try to talk to distract yourself
you know you know what it is I don't
even think it's the heat that I don't
like about saunas I just don't like
sweating no that's that's right no
that's the good part about it though
yeah I know I know that's the good part
but I I feel gross when I sweat yeah so
I think I that's the part I don't like
about saunas is that it's not even the
heat that's the issue you're about to go
back in like a bath or something right
yeah but like just sitting there just
like [ __ ] drenched in sweat I'm just
like I don't like this feeling okay you
really like saunas how do you feel about
steam rooms uh they're okay okay I feel
like steam rooms are like beta saunas in
my mind
because I'm realizing maybe it's because
I'm from Southeast Asia because I think
steam rooms feel nice so
I I like the like in my head they're
just inferious I like the heavy air in
the steam rooms you know it feels it
feels like yeah maybe maybe I just like
the heavier the humidity but I would
always prefer someone yeah because the
sauna I really hate like I hate like all
of the theater I hate like the feeling
of like sweating and it's like I don't
know my my skin feels really itchy yeah
I don't have that in Steam rooms I still
like the Heat's still a bit too hot but
I would pick a steam room over a sauna
any day of the week nah just just put me
in a nonsense bro that's right I love
the you know there's nothing more fun
than being able to chat in a sauna and
you just feel so powerful you feel like
you're like you could do anything and
you're discussing anything in the sauna
for me I'm just thinking when when is it
like a socially acceptable time to leave
like whatever you want to because I'm
I'm always that guy who's just like I
don't want to be the [ __ ]
to leave first but you're just lonely
first just because everyone has like a
different uh
but my idea of leaving first is like 20
seconds yeah yeah you don't realize
I'm in there for like 10 seconds you're
like you can leave any time and like a
second your body you're still figuring
out what the [ __ ] is going on like
you're not even heating up at that point
you're just you're still got your old
body like temperature
at least two minutes you're not you yet
if you go out at two minutes I'd be like
that's fine you're just not used to it
like five minutes is typical like five
five minutes is when you normally that's
like a normal set yeah and then you can
go out okay so okay so do you pref do
you handle being too hot or being too
cold better too cold too cold right
because I like same for me I handled too
cold better than being too hot which is
why in onsense I'm always the first one
to [ __ ] leave the bath I'm never
going in the sauna and stuff like that
because when I when it feels like my
body's cooking that's when I don't know
I just that's a much less pleasant
experience for me than being a bit too
chilly or something yeah it's weird
though it's obviously like being in like
a let's say you're a star in a jungle
it's like way less dangerous than being
stuck in like an actual cold exactly
exactly weird how our bodies I guess up
to a certain point your body's like I
love this it's like I'm actually dying
yeah I'm actually just dying I think I
think no I I think I get that uh thing
because it's like I think subconsciously
in my head I'm like it's worse being hot
because there's literally nothing I can
do after being naked yeah you know it's
like it's like I'm butt naked and I'm
still hot or that's bad but like if I'm
cold I'll just be like oh just put
another layer on yeah it's like an easy
fix but there's no easy fix when you're
butt naked and hot at the same time you
know it's like what the [ __ ] do I do let
me just
okay now I'm in danger yeah yeah
I think subconsciously I have that but
yeah again I just don't like sweating
yeah I mean no one likes no one likes I
actually I just kind of like sweating
yeah right I like sweating when it's
controlled when I'm sweating yeah like
if I'm at the gym I love sweating at the
gym like when I've got a good sweat
going man okay sweating at the gym I'm
okay with that as well because I'm doing
that to myself you know and that and
that is like a sign of like oh what I am
currently doing and spending time with
is working right but the sauna I'm not
doing anything I'm just sitting there
sweating
yeah I'm like there's no there's no
difference in going outside in Japan
there's no difference in going outside
in Japan during the summer
and turn off the sauna
the sauna is always
we installed an AC in our sauna just in
case yeah our Southeast Asians we look
at like you like Europeans like you
actually you you pay to go in a sauna
you pay to swim yeah
we just do that naturally man what are
you talking about I think there's
something like Angela Merkel always
starts her day off in a sauna or
something or something like that that
just sounds like I know every day sounds
excessive I know yeah I know it's like a
stigma but it just sounds incredibly
pretentious I I guess because like
sauna's uh outside of um certain
European countries they are a luxury yes
in certain European countries that
pretty much everywhere but but
everywhere else it's kind of like you
have to be a rich [ __ ] to have a
sauna yeah
sure well do you know anyone with that
has a sauna in their house I should go
away from the UK yeah yeah like in the
UK it's a luxury thing yeah yeah exactly
you know if you went to some European
countries it's way more common really
cool what's like having a pool in the UK
right a pool is like the biggest
indicator that you are way too much
exactly there's no there's no [ __ ]
neat reason for porn like three days a
year yeah you have five days top so you
can use that [ __ ] yeah and then you've
got a patient want to keep cleaning it
no yeah